Ein weiterer Punkt, der auch ganz wesentlich ist, ist, dass in der Art von Sportjournalismus Fans überhaupt keine Rolle spielen. Dass einfach das, was ja dann den Fußball eigentlich ausmacht und das sind die Zuschauer, dass das eigentlich überhaupt keine Rolle spielt. Und ich glaube, dass der Balesterer da halt auch ein bisschen angetreten ist, um diese Lücke zu füllen und diesen weißen Fleck irgendwie zu beseitigen.
Das war ganz gruselig. Unser Drucker sagte immer, die nächste Rechnung will ich aber voraus. Und es ist tatsächlich so, man hat keine Anzeigen, die Leute kennen einen nicht. Wenn man gesagt hat, man kommt von der Freunde, haben die Leute gedacht, das ist so ein Swinger-Club-Magazin. Also, man hatte Schwierigkeiten, den Leuten begreifbar zu machen, dass man Fußballmagazin ist. Zumal so Fußballkultur, dieses ganze Thema gab es früher einfach noch nicht.
Was müssen das für Zeiten gewesen sein, in denen es das Thema Fußballkultur noch nicht gab? Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu einem etwas überraschenden Tribünengespräch, Nummer 40 zumindest überraschend für all diejenigen von euch, die mitbekommen haben, dass die Tribünengespräche eigentlich gerade pausieren sollten bis zum Sommer. Aber besondere Zeiten erfordern besondere Umstände. Ihr habt im Intro zwei Personen gehört und die sind nicht zufällig dort gelandet. Beide begrüße ich jetzt bei mir in der Leitung. Zum einen Jakob Rosenberg, seit 2006 beim österreichischen Fußballmagazin Ballesterer und seit 2012 dort als Chefredakteur, jetzt auch immerhin schon im achten Jahr. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Und ebenfalls schön, ihn mal wieder im Rasenfunk zu haben. Ich glaube zum ersten Mal seit 2015 wieder Philipp Köster, Chefredakteur und Gründer von 11Freunde und natürlich auch als Philipp Köster auf Twitter zu finden. Hallo Philipp. Sehr schön, dass das geklappt hat. Wir wollen uns heute über Fußballmagazine unterhalten, auch angesichts der aktuellen Probleme, die der Fußball generell gerade hat. Bevor wir aber loslegen mit unserem Tribünengespräch, danke ich noch TK5, Hendrik, Philipp Nähe, der Liverpool-Fan ist und dank des Rasenfunks der Bundesliga noch nicht überdrüssig ist, der lieben D-Serie, Wohles, Sichtmonitor, Krö und Zwei-Spieler-Modus. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter und halten damit den Rasenfunk-Werbesponsoren und Paywall frei. Dafür herzlichen Dank. Und sie alle sind damit auch Mitglied im Rasenfunk-Supporters Club. Und da ist die Anzeige an dem Ballesterer quasi schon geschrieben, wegen Klaus der Idee. Denn der Ballesterer, das ist unter anderem einer der beiden Anlässe für dieses Tribünengespräch, der hat gerade seinen eigenen Supporters Club gegründet. Jakob, magst du die Hörerinnen und Hörer mal kurz ins Boot holen? Was ist da los bei euch?
Ja, und wir sind Monatsmagazine auch noch. Das macht es auch nochmal schwieriger, ständig präsent zu sein. Man kann sich auch, wenn man Fußball interessiert ist, stelle ich es mir auch schwierig vor, wenn man das ausschließlich über den Ballestra oder die 11 Freunde macht. Soll es auch geben, oder hoffe ich auch, dass es das auch gibt, aber im Prinzip, du brauchst ja auch mehrere Dinge.
Welche Rolle haben denn dann für euch die Fußballturniere im eigenen Land gespielt? Also Jakob, bei euch die EM in Schweiz und Österreich 2008. War das auch so ein wichtiger Punkt? Da warst du ja dann auch schon fest involviert, um eben im Massenmarkt bekannter zu werden und dann die paar Nischenleute sich rauszuziehen, die dann am Ballesterer hängen bleiben?
Ja, ich muss sagen, da war ich relativ neu dabei, also irgendwie seit zwei Jahren. Ich weiß, dass das Jahr 2008 für uns extrem wichtig war, weil wir extrem große Hoffnungen gehabt haben, dass jetzt der Durchbruch endlich funktioniert und dass wir endlich neue Anzeigenkunden ansprechen, dass wir viel mehr Abos verkaufen und dass wir viel mehr Einzelhefte verkaufen. Wir haben auch 2008 unsere Erscheinungsweise umgestellt. Seit 2008 kommen wir zehnmal im Jahr raus. Das heißt, wir haben da schon von der EM oder von der Stimmung, die da war, sicher profitiert. Aber ich glaube, der Philipp kann das dann für Deutschland und WM 2006 besser zählen. Ich glaube, dass das bei uns nicht in dem Ausmaß erfolgreich war wie bei den L-Freunden. Prinzipiell ist es immer schwierig zu sagen, was gewesen wäre, hätte es die EM nicht gegeben. Klar ist, dass wir dort leider auch Fehler gemacht haben oder Fehleinschätzungen gemacht haben. Wir haben zum Beispiel zur EM-Ausgabe 2008 eine CD beigelegt, die wir selbst produziert haben, mit einem Label gemeinsam. War wahnsinnig teuer und wir haben uns gedacht, ok, das wird jetzt was ändern. Hat natürlich nichts gebracht, außer dass wir sehr hohe Ausgaben hatten.
Was war denn auf der CD drauf?
Ja, da waren so Musiker aus der Indie-Szene, die irgendwelche Fußballlieder gespielt haben.
Starker Pitch schon mal.
Ein paar waren ganz gut, auch gar nicht so unbekannte Leute. Ein paar waren ganz gut, aber trotzdem wollten wir vielleicht entweder über die EM informieren.
Jakob, du klingst schon so wahnsinnig angewidert.
Nein, diese Entscheidung, diese CD zu produzieren, da kann ich die Schuld von mir weisen, war, glaube ich, eine der größten Fehlentscheidungen.
Ich habe unglaublich Lust, diese CD zu hören.
Ja, ich auch.
Das ist total schade, dass ich damals den Ballesterer… Ich habe euch genau dann kennengelernt. Also, 2008 hatte ich ja mein Praktikum bei Freunde, und da bin ich dann so eingetaucht und habe dann auch den Ballesterer abonniert gehabt. Menschen, da habe ich die CD verpasst. Das muss ja Wahnsinn sein.
Nein, aber wir haben sie noch und ist ja eine tolle CD, ein tolles Projekt, hätte alles super funktionieren können. Ich versuche mich zu retten.
Bei eBay gehen auf jeden Fall gerade die Preise in die Höhe.
Das sage ich dir jetzt halt. Ja, genau. Vielleicht finden wir noch eine Schachtel und versteigen uns dann auch im Sinne unserer Kampagne. 2008 war es auch erstmals möglich, eine professionelle Stelle zu haben. Das war aber die einzige. Sonst war das Magazin nach wie vor ehrenamtlich zum größten Teil. Das hat sich langsam, also ich würde sagen bei uns alles, immer sehr langsam in sehr kleinen Schritten entwickelt. Und so diesen Boost von einem Turnier hat es leider nicht gegeben.
Das war tatsächlich bei uns ein bisschen anders. Also diese WM 2006 war tatsächlich so ein bisschen so ein Brandbeschleuniger bei uns, weil es tatsächlich glaube ich fast beispiellos war, wie sich plötzlich unfassbar riesige gesellschaftliche Kreise für Fußball interessiert haben. Also das war sicherlich vorher ein etwas wiederer Volkssport. Dann gab es natürlich schon Professionalisierung, Kommerzialisierung, all diesen Fußballboom. Aber das hat tatsächlich dann rund um 2004, 2005 nochmal tatsächlich unvorstellbare Ausmaße in Deutschland bekommen. Da war die Euphorie tatsächlich ein bisschen anders auch noch als 2008 in Österreich, weil man auch nicht vergessen gab, vorher gab es diese tristen Jahre, diese schlimmen Europameisterschaften 2000, 2004, das ganze Land gierte irgendwie nach Erfolg und nach dieser WM und da war es dann eben plötzlich so, dass auch viele Medien, viele Leute, die irgendwas mit Fußball machen wollten, so eine Abspielfläche suchten. Und ich glaube, ich habe das nie wieder danach erlebt, dass wirklich noch jeder, der auch vorher nichts mit Fußball zu tun hatte, plötzlich über Poldi und Schweini und Klinsi und dieses ganze Nationalmannschaftsprojekt informiert war. Also, das hat in Deutschland schon was ausgelöst. Und ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass wir jetzt von diesen ganzen Fan-Meilen-Leuten profitiert haben, sondern eher davon, dass es auch ganz, ganz viele Leute gab, die ganz froh waren inmitten dieser ganzen, wie ist das immer, positiver Patriotismus, Euphorie, die Schlandisierung und die schlimmen Gesichtsfarben, Schwarz-Rot-Gold und das Gebrüll und das Krakele und das Fahnen aus dem Fenster hängen. Dass es da auch noch eine Stimme gab, die versucht hat, das alles irgendwie einzuordnen. Deswegen, glaube ich, hat das bei uns funktioniert. Das konnte man dann in den Abo-Zahlen sehen, das konnte man bei den Verkäufen sehen. Ich glaube, wir haben 2004 noch ungefähr 20.000 Hefte verkauft und dann waren es um 2006 plötzlich 35.000 oder 40.000 und das hat man richtig spürbar gemerkt. Du konntest dann in jeden Kiosk gehen und überall gab es 11 Freunde und solche Sachen haben dann einfach auf eine andere Art und Weise funktioniert als vorher. Insofern war das für uns schon wichtig. Das hat schon echt gut funktioniert. Ohne CD.
Sehr schade, was ich sehr bedauere.
Ja, es ist traurig.
Aber ganz interessante Connection zwischen Musik und auch Indie-Musik und Fußballmagazinen, die wir da haben. Also 11 Freunde, ganz lange ja vom Intro-Verlag dann herausgegeben und jetzt höre ich vom Ballesterer solche Jugend-Sünden aus dem Jahr 2008. Da könnte man mal noch übernachten.
Ich habe ein ganz schlechtes Gewissen. Nein, ich glaube, dass es auch kein Zufall ist. Weil es ja aus einer ähnlichen Subkultur kommt, diese Fans in Bewegung und irgendeine Musik interessiert. Bevor wir im nationalen Vertrieb waren, sind wir in Plattenläden aufgelegt worden. Das war auch der Ort, wo wir gehen gelernt haben. Eine total wichtige Verbindung. Einer unserer frühen Schwerpunktthemen war auch Fußball und Musik.
Bei Freunde gab es ja die Verbindung über den Intro-Verlag auch schon. Vielleicht ist das ja auch so ein bisschen sinnbildlich, Philipp. Du konntest schon immer mit Thies Ullmann über Fußball sprechen, aber nicht unbedingt mit Helene Fischer. Aber seitdem sie im Pokal-Endspiel mal singen durfte, wahrscheinlich auch mit ihr.
Nein, um Gottes Willen. Man muss tatsächlich auch so, glaube ich, als Elffreunde und auch als Ballester und glaube ich, als jedes Magazin, das sich da tummelt, schauen, dass man den allzu klebrigsten Mainstream dann doch umschifft. Also ich glaube, jedes Magazin, das sich da tummelt, jedes Magazin, das über Profenfußball berichtet, muss, glaube ich, viel aushalten an Zumutungen, die es gibt. Das finde ich nicht nur für Magazine, sondern auch für Anhänger. Du kannst ja so ein hundertprozentiger und authentischer Fußballafficionado sein. Wenn du ins Fußballstadion hineingehst, wirst du trotzdem ganz, ganz viele Dinge erleben, gegen die du nichts machen kannst. Also krakeelende Stadionsprecher, diese viertelichen Durchsagen nach Toren, die Werbeblöcke. Na ja, also letztlich ist diese Frage, inwiefern du Staffage bist für eine Verwertung dieses Sports, das ist eine Sache, mit der sich natürlich auch Kurven auseinandersetzen müssen. Jede Farbe, prächtige Choreografie ist der klassische Opener für eine Sky-Reportage und führt auch zum Verkaufen. Also insofern ist Profifußball immer etwas, was erstmal auch Schmerzen auslöst und erstmal sagt, diese ganze klebrige Inszenierung, dieser ganze Pathos, diese falschen Gefühle, die da natürlich auch irgendwie präsentiert werden. Wie schaffe ich eigentlich diesen ganzen Schrott und dieses ganze Geldgierige und dieses ganze, ich hänge allem noch ein Preisschild um und irgendwann müssen sogar die Einlaufkinder noch was dafür bezahlen, dass sie irgendwie mit aufs Spielfeld dürfen. Wie trenne ich das von dem, was authentisch ist? Und eigentlich ist das tatsächlich die Herausforderung, die man dann immer wieder hat und jeden Monat und eigentlich, wenn man das Internet dann zunimmt, jeden Tag aufs Neue hat.
Das stimmt natürlich. Ich meinte es eher so, dass man daran ablesen kann, wie einfach der Fußball in der Gesellschaft angekommen ist, dass eben jetzt Helene Fischer mit Fußball-Nationalspielern in Instagram-Stories auftaucht und das war ja unbedingt vor 20 Jahren jetzt nur nicht so. Also es gab schon immer musikalische Verbrechen im Umfeld des Fußballs. Ich meine nicht euch, Jakob.
Nein, aber damals gab es ja noch den Orgel-Spieler, der immer 78 mit ins Quartier gefahren ist. Also wenn man sich nur die Platten anguckt der Nationalmannschaft, also Udo Jürgens, Michael Schantze, Peter Alexander, dann merkt man eher, das war eher so biederes Schlager-Genre. Und natürlich ist das inzwischen so, wenn Noel Geleger und Liam Geleger sich bei City da auf der Tribüne herumtreiben, jeder englische Punk-Musiker irgendwie seinen eigenen Verein hat. Und dass da hierzulande tatsächlich auch so ist, ob es nun TS. Uhlmann mit St. Pauli ist oder Materia mit Hansa Rostock, da merkt man natürlich schon, dass wenn es auch für Indie-Künstler akzeptabel ist, zum Fußball zu gehen, dann muss sich ja wirklich was verändert haben.
Wenn ich jetzt damals bei euch in die Redaktion gekommen wäre, Philipp, lass mal bei der ersten Anfang noch, also das wäre dann quasi die Redaktion wäre die private Wohnung von Reynaldo gewesen. Was hätte ich dort vorgefunden? Du musst nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen jetzt um die privaten Details, aber was die Freunde betrifft.
Na ja, also tatsächlich war es so, dass wir ja keinen Redaktionsraum hatten, sondern dass das Wohnzimmer von Reynaldo in Friedrichshain dann wirklich unser Redaktionsraum war. Da hockte dann Reynaldo an seinem Rechner und immer mal wieder klingelte sein Privatanschluss und Abonnenten waren dran, die dann eine Adresse durchgeben wollten. Und da waren wir sehr, sehr froh, dass wir dann tatsächlich aus diesem Wohnzimmer dann nach einem Jahr in unsere ersten Redaktionsräume umgezogen sind. Da waren wir mit so einer Aktionskünstlerin Frau Karrenberg zusammen, die immer sauer war, weil wir unser benutztes Geschirr immer in die Badewanne geworfen haben. Also ich sag mal so, ich glaube, das ist ja überall so. Wenn man so was Neues gründet und seine tausend Abonnenten und seine tausend Leute hat, die das am Kiosk kaufen, dann hat man immer prekäre Verhältnisse, was so Redaktionsräume angeht. Also es war keine Garage, aber es war auch nicht das, was ich glamouröse Redaktionsräume nennen würde.
Und wie viele Artikel in den ersten Elf-Freunde-Ausgaben kamen von dir unter zum Teil haarsträubenden Synonymen? Also ich habe bis zu zehn, glaube ich, fast alle Elf-Freunde hier bei mir stehen. Also entweder sind wir sehr internationale Schreiberlinge oder du warst irgendwann zu faul, dir Pseudonyme auszudenken.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich irgendwann tatsächlich einfach nur noch im Telefonbuch geschaut und wahllos an Nachnamen gereiht. Also es war natürlich auch so, dass ganz, ganz viele Leute, von denen wir dachten, die schaffen es auf jeden Fall intelligent über Fußball zu schreiben, dass die gesagt haben, ja gerne, aber nur mit Honorar. Und das war tatsächlich für uns gar nicht machbar. Und wir fanden es jetzt auch öde, wenn dann unter allen Fotos Renaldo Kudu und unter allen Texten Philipp Köster steht. Insofern haben wir dann ein bisschen angefangen, dann auch uns noch Pseudonyme zuzulegen, teilweise auch mit, also Renaldo mit seinen Fotos. Das hat Gott sei Dank irgendwann aufgehört, weil wir tatsächlich ganz viele Leute so aus unserer Fansin-Bekannschaft noch herangezogen haben, die es gewohnt waren, ausgebeutet zu werden. Aber vorher war das ganz schön anstrengend. Also gerade die ersten Ausgaben, die inzwischen ja auch bei Ebay durchaus hoch gehandelt werden, da stehen teilweise Sachen drin, von denen ich mich noch erinnere, dass ich kurz vor Tore Schluss noch zusammengeknüppelt habe. Das ist heute auch nicht mehr so richtig gut lesbar. Manches Frühwerk tut da noch echt weh, beim heute Lesen.
Na gut, das geht ja jedem so, der mal etwas erschaffen hat und Jahre später draufguckt.
Die erste Rasenfunk-Sendung, kannst du dir die heute noch anhören?
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist alles fürchterlich. Also wirklich alles von vorne bis hinten unerträglich. Ich möchte jedem davon abraten. Habe ich es noch abrufbar. Es ist noch abrufbar.
Bringt er vielleicht mal als CD raus, habe ich mir überlegt.
Bei der nächsten EM vielleicht.
Ja, das ist 2024. Das wird dann der Sargnagel auch für 11 Freunde.
Und Rasenfunk kannst du dann auch zumachen.
Ja, Rasenfunk, ob es den dann auch gibt. Jakob, wie war es denn bei dir? Als du das erste Mal in der Ballestere-Redaktion war, wann war das dann? 2006, 2005, so um den Dreh rum?
Ja, genau, das war 2006. Also genau, das erste Treffen im Ballestere war auch gar nicht mehr in der Redaktion, sondern das war im Kaffeehaus. Ist ja ein Wiener Magazin. Also da habe ich einfach, ich habe quasi gesehen, dass der Ballester einen Marathonerschwerpunkt plant und ich bin gerade aus Neapel zurück und habe mir gedacht, vielleicht kann ich dir etwas beisteuern und habe halt irgendwie dem Chefredakteur quasi ein Mail geschrieben und gefragt und er hat gemeint, ja, treffen wir uns mal im Kaffee und so ist das entstanden. Damals haben wir doch sehr langfristig gedacht, also diese Ankündigung war irgendwie, glaube ich, ein Dreivierteljahr oder ein Jahr fast, bevor da der Schwerpunkt hätte stattfinden sollen. Dazwischen war die WM 2006 und dort, da gab es so ein, also ich sage jetzt nicht Public Viewing dazu, weil das wird dem nicht entsprechen, sondern es gab halt ein Lokal, wo die Valestra-Leute gemeinsam die Spiele geschaut haben. Und dort bin ich dann vorbeigekommen, also das heißt, die ersten Treffen waren alle irgendwie mit Lokalen verbunden und habe halt dann mit dem Reinhardt geplaudert und irgendwie, damals war halt Cacciopoli der Skandal und ich habe halt irgendwie dadurch, dass ich gerade in Italien meine Kontakte dort auch gehabt habe, zumindest italienisch können und habe halt auch angeboten, was zu schreiben zu einem Nebenaspekt und so bin ich dann schon vor der Marathoner-Ausgabe quasi reingerutscht. Und dann die ersten Treffen, da muss ich sagen, das damalige Redaktionsbüro war großartig. Das haben wir gemeinsam mit einer Literaturzeitschrift Zentrale Lage, Innenstadt, war toll. Da mussten wir dann leider irgendwann raus. Jetzt sind wir immer noch relativ zentral, hatten am Anfang auch noch eine Kooperation mit der Literaturzeitschrift, sind mittlerweile aber quasi in einer Erdgeschosswohnung, in einer umgebauten allein. Und da würde ich sagen, ich weiß nicht, wann waren wir euch besuchen, Philipp, in Berlin 2014?
Ich glaube 2013, wenn es um dieses Treffen der Fußballmagazinmacher aus ganz Europa geht.
Genau, dann 2013, da waren wir schwer beeindruckt, wie euer Büro dort ausgeschaut hat. Also das ist nicht vergleichbar. Bei uns ist es quasi ein großer Raum, viel Badewanne gibt es auch als Lager und so weiter.
Also kein Kaffegeschirr in der Badewanne, sondern Balesterer-Ausgaben?
Ja, Balesterer oder irgendwelche alten Stühle, die wir irgendwie nicht mehr verwenden oder alles Mögliche.
Okay, ich frage nicht weit. Ja, Philipp, bei euch hat sich das ja schnell professionalisiert. Also aus der Privatwohnung heraus ging es dann in die Wohnung mit der Künstlerin und dann später an den Prenzlauer Berg, da war dann auch ich, mal kurz für drei Monate, glaube ich, im Jahr 2008. Da kann ich mich jetzt noch daran erinnern. Und ich hatte damals, als Praktikant hat man ja die Aufgabe, unter anderem die Tür zu öffnen, wenn geklingelt wird. Im meisten Fall war es der Postbote und man musste irgendwie eins von 200 Paketen entgegennehmen und an der Wand stapeln. Es waren aber hin und wieder auch Leute aus der Fußballszene. Ich erinnere mich da noch an eine sehr lustige Begegnung mit Andreas Rettig, an die er keine Erinnerung mehr hat. Ich habe ihn mal danach gefragt. Möchte er aber deswegen jetzt auch nicht hier in den Podcast ziehen. Wie war denn aber so der Eindruck, den ihr hinterlassen habt bei Leuten aus dem Fußballgeschäft? Wie lang hat es denn gedauert, bis ihr da ernst genommen wurdet?
Also am Anfang war es tatsächlich so, dass einem offene Ignoranz begegnet ist. Da wird immer gerne der Hertha-Pressesprecher von damals zitiert, dessen Name ich jetzt nicht nennen würde, sonst könnte man Hansi Fälser zu leicht erkennen. Nämlich der dann sagte, kommt doch wieder, wenn ihr 100.000 Auflage habt und vorher brauchte gar nicht bei uns anzuklingeln. Andere haben uns einfach weggedrückt, wenn wir da angerufen haben. Und ich glaube, das ging so nach und nach einfach immer weiter, so dass Spieler, die bei uns dann zum Interview waren, auch in der Lage waren, das weiter zu erzählen, dass es ganz angenehm war, dass man schöne Fotos gemacht hat. Also es ist ja bis heute so, dass eigentlich unser Anspruch ist, dass wir wirklich jeden unserer Artikel mit eigenen Bildern bebildern, also dass wir keine Stockfotos, keine Agenturen benutzen, möglichst wenig, wenn es nicht gerade historische Ereignisse sind. Also das haben Spieler, Trainer, Funktionäre auch zu schätzen gewusst, dass sie bei uns länger reden können als normal und dass nicht jeder Satz so verkürzt wird, dass eine Schlagzeile draus wird. Es gibt natürlich so ein paar Leute, die dann tatsächlich so Freunde des Hauses geworden sind. Also Andi Rettig gehört tatsächlich dazu, Thomas Hitzelsberger ist so jemand, aber vor allen Dingen Ewald Lin, der seinen Sohn bei uns als Praktikanten hatte und irgendwann einfach bei uns vor der Tür stand und dann sah, dass bei uns ein Schreibtisch frei war und sich dann einfach hingesetzt hat. Er blieb dann einfach zwei Wochen bei uns, Ewald, und hat an einem Rechner von uns bei Transfermarkt.de seinen Kader für Panionios Athen zusammengestellt. Da werde ich nie vergessen, wie sein Sohn immer hinter ihm schon sagte, der ist gut, den muss er auch noch kaufen. Und Ewald telefonierte dann immer mit einem griechischen Gewährsmann in Athen, Georgios, und gab dann immer die Transfers durch. Und ich glaube, manch ein Praktikant bei uns hat echt einen Herzinfarkt gekriegt, wenn der dann morgens reinkam und dann sah es Ewald da schon und hat schon Spieler gesichtet. Also ich glaube, dass es aber trotz allem auch ganz gut ist, jetzt mal abseits der paar persönlichen Freundschaften, die wir natürlich so hatten, dass wir auch immer eine gewisse Distanz gewahrt haben. Also wenn man sich natürlich anguckt, dass ganz, ganz viel in diesem Business, sehr viel über diese Kumpellei läuft, da hat der eine Mann dem anderen Gefallen getan und dafür darf der dann wieder beim Doppelpass noch was erzählen und der hat da noch ein Geheimnis, das steckt da dem und also diese ganzen untereinander Gefälligkeiten, die es da so gibt, da hat sich Elf-Freunde tatsächlich immer weitgehend rausgehalten. Natürlich verstehen wir uns auch mit manchen aus dem Business besser als mit den anderen, aber ich glaube, dass insgesamt es eigentlich wenige Leute gibt, die uns in offener Feindschaft zugetan sind und andersrum aber auch wenige, mit denen wir uns ständig in die Arme fallen und sagen, ey, was seid ihr denn für Supertypen? Und ich glaube, dass das Elf-Freunde so, was die Distanz angeht, eigentlich ganz gut tut.
Jakob, wie hat sich denn die Akzeptanz vom Ballesterer über die Jahre hinweg verändert?
Ja, ich würde sagen, der Anfang ist ähnlich.
Evald Linen hat bei euch auch einen Kader zusammengestellt.
Ja, Evald Linen war dann drei Wochen bei uns. Wir haben am Anfang sehr stark kämpfen müssen, quasi um Akkreditierungen, um Interviews, um generell Umaufmerksamkeit, das hat sich langsam, aber stetig verbessert. Jetzt, am österreichischen Markt oder so, haben wir da eigentlich gar keine Probleme mehr. International kommt es darauf an. Bei sehr großen Clubs tun wir uns immer noch schwer, zu sagen, wenn wir einen Liverpool-Schwerpunkt planen, rechnen wir das Club-Interview nicht ein. Das wäre unrealistisch. Wir probieren es dann vielleicht, aber da sind wir natürlich zu klein. Das interessiert die ganz Großen nicht. Aber im Prinzip würde ich sagen, dass die Akzeptanz auf jeden Fall stark gestiegen ist. Ich glaube, diese Kumpellei, wie es Philipp genannt hat, gibt es bei uns den Fachbegriff Verhaberung. Das ist sicher etwas, wo man natürlich aufpassen muss und wo man schauen muss, dass man da nicht dabei ist. Das sind wir auch und da achten wir sehr genau drauf, weil ich glaube, gerade für ein Magazin wie unseres, das sich irgendwie auf die Fahnen heftet, wir schauen, dass wir kritisch sind, wir schauen, dass wir unabhängig sind, dann kann man nicht solche Nebendeals laufen lassen.
Aber woher kommt denn das, dass es im Fußball so verbreitet ist? Wenn man jetzt einfach mal den Journalismus als Ganzes betrachtet und sich dann den Sport- und den Fußball-Journalismus herauspickt, dann würde ich behaupten, dass es wenige andere Bereiche, vielleicht noch Motor – nee, nicht Motorsport, sondern Autosjournalismus, vielleicht noch Reisejournalismus, aber es gibt ganz wenige Bereiche, bei denen eben die Verschränkung zwischen Journalisten und Akteuren der Branche so eng ist wie beim Fußball. Und ich frage mich manchmal, woher das eigentlich kommt.
Also ich glaube, beim Skifahren ist es noch viel schlimmer. Oh ja, stimmt.
Das ist die österreichische Perspektive.
Nein, aber da gibt es ja da nicht so diesen Spruch ab, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Meter gibt es, kein Sieh mehr und so weiter. Na, ich glaube aber tatsächlich, dass es diese Verhaberung oder diese Versuche der Verhaberung, dass es die in allen Bereichen gibt. Ich glaube, dass es im Sport vielleicht noch mal klarer wird oder dass es im Sport insofern leichter wird, weil man irgendwie dieses Thema hat und wo man ja auch alle, sind ja alle für einen Sport und das wollen ja alle guten Fußball sehen und was weiß ich was. Da versucht man schnell irgendwie so eine Vereinnahmung herzustellen. Aber ich glaube, dass es so Phänomene, dass irgendwie Pressesprecher oder auch Akteure aus Unternehmen, Politiker, was auch immer, dass die versuchen, die Paar Journalisten, die für sie zuständig sind, quasi einzukochen. Ich glaube, das gibt es ganz sicher überall und ist ein Problem, würde ich sagen, vor allem von Ressourcen des Journalismus. Und da gehen wir über den Sportjournalismus weit heraus. Also wenn man sagt, es gibt einfach zu wenig Stellen im Journalismus, um Dinge gut zu recherchieren, dann kriegt man halt schlecht recherchierte Pressemitteilungen, die man halt leicht ändert, aber wo auch nicht die Zeit ist, da mehr zu machen.
Das glaube ich auch. Und das ist natürlich auch vielleicht nicht ganz so kulturpessimistisch, wie du das formuliert hast, Max. Ich glaube, dass du viele Branchen hast, wo es ein wahnsinniges bussige Tour und, wie Jakob das so schön genannt hat, Verhaberung gibt. Nämlich dort, wo es darum geht, mit Gefälligkeiten und mit Informationen zu handeln. Wenn ich mir die Schlagerbranche angucke und anderes, da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch unfassbar viele Deals und Absprachen. Ich glaube aber, im Fußball ist es eben auch so, dass die eigentliche Nichtigkeit des Gegensteines, also Fußball ist ja entgegen unserer aller Art, das zu einer lebensentscheidenden Sache hochzuheben. Am Ende natürlich auch nur Sport und Entertainment und Unterhaltung und so weiter. Und die Frage ist, was für News gibt es denn da eigentlich, die gehandelt werden können? Und da befinden sich natürlich manche, also Pressesprecher, Trainer, Funktionäre, in der wunderbaren Situation, Günstlinge sich zu halten, denen man Informationen zusteckt, weil das so eine Ware ist, mit der man oder eine Währung auch mit der man so handeln kann. Insofern glaube ich, ist der Fußball mit seinen ganz vielen kleinen Tratschgeschichten, seinen Geheimnissen, seinen ganzen Abgründen ein bisschen prädestiniert, um gerade auch so eine ganz spezielle Art von Gefälligkeitsjournalismus dann auch zu provozieren. Und ich glaube, dass es viele Kollegen gibt, die sich dem entziehen. Also das passiert bei Spiegel Online und bei der SZ und bei der Zeit und anderswo sicherlich genauso. Aber es gibt auch viele, die nichts großartiger finden, als ihr Handy hochzurecken und Selfies mit den Stars zu machen und mit denen Deals auszuhandeln und mit denen sogenannte bunte Geschichten zu machen und Tratsch weiterzutreiben. Und ich glaube, dass das so zwei Aspekte von Sportjournalismus sind, die manchmal auch auf unangenehme Art und Weise aufeinanderprallen.
Und gleichzeitig entzieht ihr euch ja mit euren Magazinen allein schon durch die monatliche Erscheinungsweise so ein bisschen diesem Newszyklus, in dem man dann eben nicht mitmachen muss. Also Freunde, macht da mit, aber auf eine sehr verfluchte Art und Weise, in dem Covergeschichten kurz danach sind die entsprechenden Spieler verletzt oder entlassen oder wie auch immer.
Oder Jürgen Klinsmann ist zurück in den USA, ab dem wir noch verkündet haben, dass er jetzt mal richtig angreift, der Jürgen.
Wobei, das war ja schon wieder so passend zu dieser abstrusen Situation, dass es ja fast trotzdem ein Kaufanreiz war, dass wir sich gedacht haben, ok, da will ich jetzt nochmal eintauchen in diese Welt von vor einer Woche.
Das hat tatsächlich auch, obwohl es tatsächlich dann ein bisschen obsolet war, das Cover als Magazin oder als Verkauf echt sehr, sehr gut geklappt. Trotzdem war es ein bisschen nervig, weil man sich natürlich gewünscht hätte, dass dieser Klinsi-Wahnsinn noch mal ein paar Tage weitergeht.
Aber davon abgesehen halten sich monatliche Publikationen ein bisschen aus diesen üblichen Mechanismen. Ich muss jetzt exklusiv melden, was ich gehört habe, ein bisschen raus. Und auf der anderen Seite hat man aber eben das Problem, was ja vorhin Jakob auch schon angesprochen hat, dass man als monatlich erscheinendes Medium eben nicht so viel Grundaufmerksamkeit bekommt und eben weniger mögliche Kontaktpunkte hat zu Leserinnen und Lesern. Welches Problem ist jetzt größer? Das, dass man so wenig Aufmerksamkeit hat und damit dann vielleicht auch mit einem veränderten Mediennutzungsverhalten konfrontiert wird? Oder eben das, dass man sich auf andere Themen konzentrieren kann? Das ist kein Problem, das war jetzt falsch von mir anmoderiert, sondern ist eine Chance. Also wie würdet ihr diese Abwägungen jetzt in eurer aktuellen Lage für euch bewerten?
Für uns als Elf-Freunde war es ja eigentlich immer wichtig, tatsächlich so den Blick mal über reine Fan-Themen hinaus zu richten, aus zwei der Gründen. Also erstens glaube ich, dass das, was wir uns um das Jahr 2000 quasi so auf die Fahnen geschrieben hatten, im Jahr 2010, 2012 oder 2020 nicht mehr so entscheidend ist für den Anhänger. Also ich weiß, wie wir uns 2000 den Mund fusselig geredet haben, wie ätzend wir das finden, dass jetzt diese ganzen Stadien umbenannt werden. Dass nicht mehr Alm und Betzenberg – oder Betzenberg ist ja tatsächlich sogar noch Fritz-Weiter-Stadion, aber dass die Alm nicht mehr Alm heißt und das Volksparkstadion nicht mehr Volksparkstadion und das Waldstadion dann Commerzbank Arena wird und so weiter. Also dass die alle heißen wie Firmenparkplätze, das fanden wir natürlich ätzend. Der Punkt ist nur, wenn du das heutzutage Leuten erzählst oder wenn wir zum Beispiel auf unsere Stadionposter noch die alten Namen draufschreiben, da gibt es echt viele, die sagen, Leute, das sind Diskussionen aus dem vergangenen Jahrhundert. Das ist nicht mehr unser Thema. Das Gleiche ist so bei so Themen wie Stehplätzen. Da, glaube ich, gibt es inzwischen ein allgemeines Agreement in der Liga, dass es eine gewisse Masse an Stehplätzen geben soll. Und selbst wenn es immer mal wieder durchgeknallte Innenminister gibt, die sagen, die schaffen wir jetzt mal als nächstes ab, glaube ich, will das niemand in der Liga, weil die Leute kapiert haben, dass dort eine andere Kultur herrscht als auf den Sitzplätzen. Aber ich glaube, insgesamt war es für Elf-Freunde einfach wichtig zu schauen, dass es ganz, ganz viele unterschiedliche Arten gibt, Fußball zu lieben und auch dieser Fußballkultur authentisch Ausdruck zu geben. Und dass es schade wäre, wenn wir sagen, Fan-Themen sind das Einzige, was wir so machen wollen. Insofern war es für uns wichtig, dass wir uns auch mit den Akteuren des Spiels unterhalten. So einer wie Mats Hummels zum Beispiel, jetzt in der aktuellen Ausgabe. Mit dem reden wir ja gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel darüber, wie er sich nun im System von Favre sieht, sondern wir reden mit dem auch darüber, wie er sich zur AfD positioniert. Und wir reden mit ihm darüber, warum er der österreichischen Publizistin Natascha Strobl folgt, die ihrerseits auf Twitter ja diese ganz großartigen Analysen von diesem ganzen, ganzen rechtsnationalen Wahnsinn macht. Also ich fände es total schade, uns selbst zu beschränken und zu sagen, wir reden nicht mit Mats Hummels, weil das wird ja eh blöd, sondern ich glaube, dass gute Interviews und gute Vorbereitung und Interesse am Gegenüber und Interesse am Spieler und auch an anderen dazu führen kann, dass auch Spieler was Intelligentes sagen. Und gerade das Interview mit Mats Hummels ist dafür meiner Meinung nach auch ein Beleg, dass das funktionieren kann.
Und trotzdem haben sich ja so ein bisschen die Medien-Nutzungsarten verändert.
Ich habe gar nicht auf deine Frage geantwortet, ne?
Der alte Politiker Köster ist da wieder rausgekommen.
Dann sage ich noch einen einzigen Satz und dann darf Jakob rein. Also die Medien-Nutzung hat sich natürlich verändert. Es gibt doch diese Szene bei diesem Facebook-Film, wo einer der beiden Gründer, Eduardo Severin, irgendwie dann mit diesem Napster-Gründer aneinandergerät. Und dann sagt der Napster-Gründer zu ihm noch, pass mal auf, wenn du jetzt was machen würdest, du würdest auch keinen Plattenladen gründen. Ich glaube, als es darum ging, ob Napstern Erfolg war. Und ich glaube, genauso ist es eben auch bei dem Printmagazin. Man wird jetzt heute auch keinen Kiosk aufmachen, weil man denkt, das ist jetzt eine total geile Sache, weil das ist jetzt irgendwie das Geschäft der Zukunft. Natürlich hat sich das alles geändert. Und natürlich gibt es immer weniger Präsenz für Printmagazine. Wenn ich heute von Prenzlauer Berg nach Friedrichshain fahre, ist es immer so, dass nahezu bei jedem Trip darunter ein Kiosk mehr zugemacht hat oder ein Kiosk weniger Elfreunde führt, weil die nur noch so ein paar Brigitte, Sternen und die Tageszeitungen haben. Also ich glaube schon, wir als Ballestra, als Elfreunde, als auch andere Printmagazine müssen uns natürlich dem stell, dass die Leute eher ins Internet gucken, wenn sie was Neues wissen wollen und dass es im Internet inzwischen auch unfassbar viele tolle Sachen gibt. Ich glaube, keines der beiden Magazine verweigert sich ja dem Internet. Also wir sind da ja beide sehr aktiv. Insofern ist das schon alles okay so.
Na gut, aber das Geldverdienen ist halt so viel schwieriger im Internet. Also ihr habt natürlich zum Beispiel mit dem Live-Ticker sogar – da hat es ja sogar etwas aus dem Internet irgendwann ins Heft geschafft. Das ist ja das perfekte Paradoxon. Aber dennoch begegnest du im Internet eben der Realität, dass es viel, viel schwieriger ist, noch Geld zu verdienen, weil die Anzeigenpreise völlig versaut sind durch die Durchanalysierbarkeit jedweder Daten und dann wird – dann werden da ganz fürchterliche Ads geschaltet, damit überhaupt noch irgendjemand da draufklickt. Amerikanische Forscher haben herausgefunden, so nehmen sie 100 Kilo ab in zwei Tagen und so ein Kram. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es zwar die Bewegung, dass Leute durchaus bereit sind, auch im Internet Geld für Dienstleistungen zu bezahlen. Der Rasenfunk ist da ja auch ein ganz kleines Beispiel. Aber da steht halt ein unglaublicher Aufwand dahinter, das anzuschieben. Also noch ist das nicht einfach nur, hey, wir schalten jetzt hier unser Magazin auch in eine Online-Variante verfügbar und dann rollt der Rubel auch digital rein. So einfach ist es ja noch nicht.
Nein, ich glaube, das wird überhaupt nicht funktionieren. Ich glaube auch, es gibt eine Printkrise und ich glaube, es tun sich alle Magazine gerade schwer. Aber ich glaube, es gibt auch eine Online-Krise. Also es gibt für Unabhängigen, Kritischen vielleicht auch etwas längeren, hintergründigeren Journalismus im Internet, kein Geschäftsmodell. Also wenn man sich anschaut, wir haben das auch im aktuellen Heft irgendwie kurz drin, Republik in der Schweiz. Tolles Projekt, tolle Leute dahinter, super durchfinanziert irgendwie das erste Jahr. Da kann man sagen, ok, eigentlich von dem, was sie da anbieten wollen, alles großartig und ja, man merkt, diese Texte funktionieren dort auch nicht. Das heißt, mit dem Internet muss man anders umgehen. Also ich glaube, zu sagen, wir transferieren den Balesterer ins Netz, ich glaube, das funktioniert gar nicht. Ich glaube, man kann sich überlegen, wie schauen, wie kann ein Internet auftreten und das Heft sich gut ergänzen. Also wie das Beispiel jetzt von dir auch, wenn es da Synergien gibt, wenn das eine und das andere wechseln und so weiter, super, dann toll gemacht. Aber im Prinzip glaube ich, dass es auch sehr schwer gerade ist, einen Blog zu gründen oder eine Webseite zu gründen, die jetzt von Werbeeinnahmen oder was auch immer allein lebt. Also ich glaube, das funktioniert ohne irgendwie ein Unterstützungsmodell oder so, wenn man nicht irgendwie nur auf Clickbait setzt.
Das glaube ich auch. Und natürlich ist es manchmal ein Glücksfall, wenn einem irgendetwas gelingt, was ein bisschen stilprägend ist. Also das war bei uns ja vor allen Dingen der Live-Ticker, der ja dann auch vielfältig kopiert worden ist. Also diese neue Form des Journalismus und eben nicht nur 102030 zu vermelden. Aber mir hat das mal ein gruner Mitarbeiter bitter vorgerechnet, was so die Kapitalisierung angeht. Dass du tatsächlich von 100 Euro, die du für eine Print-Anzeige einnehmen würdest, also was die Kontakte angeht, dafür bleiben dann beim Desktop, also auf dem stationären Computer, noch 10 Euro und im mobilen Web bleiben dir 1 Euro bei gleichzeitiger Leistung so. Und ich glaube, dass dieser Geburtsfehler oder ich würde mal sagen, dass diese Unwucht gerade für Magazine und auch für Verlage, die von der Rentabilität von Printprodukten leben, nicht einfach ist. Du siehst, du kannst das, was du vorher eingenommen hast, nicht annähernd wieder reinholen. Deswegen gibt es glaube ich auch ganz viele Verlage, die die Digitalisierung so lange verschleppen, wie es nur irgendwie geht, in der Hoffnung, dass die Magazine noch weiter irgendwie Geld einbringen.
Und wie ist das jetzt dann in dem Fall von euren beiden Heften gelagert? Also ich nehme jetzt einfach mal an, Philipp, dass es bei euch so sein wird, dass das Durchschnittsalter der Abonnenten, die die wichtigste Käufergruppe sind, dass das eher steigt, als dass es sinkt. Was ja, wenn man jetzt den Zeitraum von den nächsten fünf Jahren vielleicht mal aufmacht, nicht einfach nur von Monat oder von Quartal zu Quartal denkt, irgendwann zu einem Problem werden könnte. Wie könnt ihr das denn schaffen, diesem Trend entgegenzustehen?
Also tatsächlich ist die nicht überaltert. Also die sterben jetzt nicht weg, unsere Abonnenten. Wir sind nicht die CDU und wir sind nicht der Gong. Da haben wir tatsächlich, glaube ich, den Vorteil, dass Fußball Gott sei Dank ja eine lebenslange Beschäftigung ist. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass wir, was so das Printmagazin angeht, eine Zielgruppe haben, die erst so ab 30 anfängt. Das ist echt vollkommen anders als im Internet. Also das muss man echt mal sagen. Es kommen wahnsinnig viele Leute zu unserer Lesung zum Beispiel, die uns vor allen Dingen über den Live-Ticker, vor allen Dingen übers Internet kennen. Wir haben auch schon Praktikanten gehabt, die total überrascht waren, dass wir nicht nur eine Facebook-Seite sind. Da ist man doch auch immer mal wieder überrascht. Aber tatsächlich ist es noch mal so, dass das Genre des Zeitschriften-Abos als solches jetzt nicht das hippste Produkt ist, das man so irgendwie verkaufen kann. Also es gibt Leute, die das schätzen. Es gibt auch junge Leute, die das schätzen. Aber so, dass das wie früher wäre, wo jeder, der irgendwie zu Hause auszog, als allererstes von seinen Eltern die Lokalzeitung im Abo bekommen hat und wo es ganz selbstverständlich war, dass man sich so zwei, drei Blätter gehalten hat. Ich glaube, dass die Zeiten vorbei sind. Man muss heute um jeden Abonnenten ringen. Und deswegen ist es eigentlich auch für uns schon frühzeitig eher ein Modell gewesen, zu sagen, wir wollen gar nicht, dass die nur Abonnenten sind, sondern die sollen eigentlich näher an uns ranrücken. Weil wir natürlich auch feststellen, dass wir von ganz, ganz vielen Leuten, die uns abonniert haben, die Ideen haben, die neue Sichtweisen haben, wir auch sehr profitieren können. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich sogar das, was für mich durch die Digitalisierung als allergreifbarste Vorteil ist, dass diese eindimensionale Senderhaltung, die vorher Magazine hatten, dass man nur Sachen aussendet und hofft, dass das Gefallen bringt, sich in einen Dialog gewandelt hat. Das finde ich eigentlich das Allerbeste, dass man viele, viele neue Perspektiven kennenlernt, Leute, die ihre Stimme erheben können. Das ist eigentlich sogar, finde ich, wenn ich jetzt zu den Vorteilen der Digitalisierung betrachten würde, dass aus einem monologen Dialog geworden ist eigentlich sogar das erhebendste und spannendste.
Aber müsst ihr dann nicht zwangsläufig auch ein bisschen weg irgendwann vom Kern des Printprodukts – also du hast ja schon gesagt, dass ihr Abonnenten besonders binden wollt, das ergibt ja auch Sinn – aber die müssen ja immer noch die Liebe zu einem Printprodukt haben, die ja nicht mehr so weit verbreitet ist wie früher noch vielleicht.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also eigentlich wird das ja schon so sein, dass – das ist ja absehbar – dass du natürlich alles, was du momentan bei uns im Heft liest, auch digital lesen kannst. Du kannst ja heute natürlich schon irgendwie so Emacs und so weiter runterladen, ob es dann als PDF ist oder auch als aufbereitete Variante. Aber entscheidend wird schon sein, dass du natürlich irgendwie eigentlich nicht mehr unbedingt dir das haptische Heft liefern lassen musst, um mehr Freundeabonnent zu sein. Also das war ja so ein bisschen das Prinzip, dass wir mit dieser Dauerkarte haben, also dass wir sagen, pass mal auf, wenn du das Ding dir holst, dann kannst du natürlich auch alles, alles, alles, ohne dass du einmal irgendwie das Heft in die Hand nehmen musst, natürlich auch digital lesen. Nur, ich sag, also für mich ist das ja so, ich bin seit ich zwölf oder dreizehn bin von Magazinen fasziniert. Also ich wollte nie was anderes machen, also ich wusste so mit zwölf, dreizehn, dass ich irgendwie so in diesen Magazinjournalismus will. Und ich hab nach wie vor, ich würd's nicht sagen, kein erotisches Verhältnis zum Magazin machen, aber tatsächlich finde ich nichts aufregender, als wenn bei uns der Postbote endlich kommt und unsere Hefte in die Redaktion bringt und wir das aufmachen. Ja, es ist ein erotisches Verhältnis. Wie so ein Print-Tinder-Date quasi. Also ich finde das nach wie vor immer den aufregendsten Moment, das Ding rauszuholen, durchzublättern, das in der Hand zu haben, zu gucken, wie funktioniert die Heftmischung, fühlen sich die Leser da gut durchgeleitet. Also mir würde was sehr, sehr fehlen, wenn wir irgendwann alle Freunde nur noch digital hätten und nicht als Heft, dass du dir auch in den Schrank stellen kannst und dass du durchblättern kannst und das auf deinem Schreibtisch oder auf deinem Nachttisch liegt.
Jakob, bei euch ist die Situation ja logischerweise etwas extremer gerade, deswegen ja auch die Ballesterer-Rentkampagne. Wie würdest du sagen, hat sich bei euch das niedergeschlagen, dass sich der Markt für Fußballmagazine verändert hat? Und welchen Weg daraus gibt's?
Ja, ich glaube, dass der Markt einfach von von vornherein schwierig war und seit 20 Jahren schwierig ist. Also da gibt es halt auch nochmal den großen Unterschied natürlich zwischen den unterschiedlichen Märkten in Österreich und Deutschland und auch den großen Unterschied, wie populär ist Fußball in den jeweiligen Ländern? Also ich glaube, dass man da einfach ganz andere Entwicklungen natürlich auch sieht.
Also der Wedler, das Skisportmagazin, wäre erfolgreicher als der Ballester?
Skifix ist die Idee. Na, na, Skifix haben wir schon diejenigen, die aus anderen Bundesländern aus Wien kommen, schon geplant. Nein, glaube ich auch nicht. Also Fußball ist schon der populärste Sport in Österreich, aber es ist halt trotzdem nicht so ein Massenphänomen wie in Deutschland, wo irgendwie jedes Stadion bis in die dritte Liga hinein voll ist. Bei uns gibt es halt ein paar Stadien, die gut gefüllt sind, aber auch alles sehr starken Schwankungen immer unterworfen. Prinzipiell, ich glaube, was diese Frage Online-Print betrifft, ich glaube schon, dass das Magazine oder Special-Interest-Magazine, vor allem Special-Interest-Magazine, eigentlich diejenigen sind, die für die Printkrise am besten gewappnet sind, weil es da sowieso nicht um Tagesaktualität geht. Das heißt, jemand, der sich dafür entscheidet, die L-Freunde oder einen Ballestra zu kaufen, der macht das nicht, weil er irgendein Matchergebnis haben will oder weil er über die neuesten Nachrichten des Tages informiert werden will, wie jemand, der eine Tageszeitung kauft. Also ich glaube, dass wir da schon einen Vorteil haben und ich glaube auch, dass es Leute gibt, die dieses haptische, also da Philipp hat jetzt dieses erotische Verhältnis genannt, ich glaube, dass das gar nicht nur diejenigen haben, die das Magazin produzieren, sondern ich glaube, dass das auch den Lesern und Leserinnen von Magazinen oft so geht. Also die wollen was in der Hand haben, die wollen sich das anschauen, die wollen das lesen oder vielleicht auch nicht alles lesen. Also es liegt dann oft einmal ein Monat herum und vielleicht packt man es in zwei Monaten wieder aus oder wir riechen und man schaut nochmal rein. Und ich glaube, dass das was ist, was auch eben im Print nach wie vor funktioniert. Ich glaube, dass es natürlich ein Problem gibt, wenn es viele Leute gibt, die an das gar nicht mehr gewöhnt sind oder wenn man sagt, es wird einfach weniger Zeit und gelesen. Ich glaube, dass man das online halt auch irgendwie mitbespielen muss. Aber ich glaube auch, dass es – ich weiß nicht, wie ich das formulieren soll, aber ich glaube, das was wir können und das was wir in den letzten 20 Jahren gelernt haben, ist, ein Printmagazin zu machen mit hintergründigen Texten, mit Schwerpunkten, das versucht irgendwie ein oder viele Themen, die mit dem Fußball zu tun haben, die bestmöglich zu beachten. Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, wir wollen jetzt schauen, wie können wir, irgendwie weil sich die Lesegewohnheiten verändert haben, ist für mich die Frage, wie können wir das übersetzen, wie können wir das, was wir jetzt können, auch in anderen Bereichen bestmöglich machen. Was aber nicht geht ist zu sagen, okay, und wir konkurrieren jetzt mit irgendeinem lustigen Online-Medium, das irgendwie schaut, was alle paar Minuten neu rauskommt und was die letzte Transfer-Marktspekulation oder was auch immer ist. Also ich glaube, man muss da noch einen Weg finden, wie man Leute ansprechen kann. Prinzipiell glaube ich, dass der Ballesterer geschätzt wird für die Themen und für die Sicht und für das, wie er Themen anschaut und ich glaube, da muss man halt schauen, gibt es da Arten, wie man das besser machen kann, wenn sich der Markt so verändert. Das ist schwieriger. Mir hat das Bild von Philipp vorher mit dem Dialog gefallen. Man kann vielleicht sogar einen Polilog draus machen. Ich würde sagen, man tritt mit den Leserinnen auch Stärke in ein Verhältnis. Also ich würde auch sagen, dass das für den Ballesterer immer was total Wesentliches war. Ich würde sagen, wir rekrutieren uns vor allem neu auch aus Lesern und Leserinnen. Wir haben nicht diese professionellen Strukturen, wo man sagt, du musst jetzt irgendwie Publizistik studiert haben oder die FA gemacht haben, dann vier Praktika gemacht haben und bei so und so viele Zeitungen schon gearbeitet haben, um für uns schreiben zu können, sondern die meisten Leute, die neu dazukommen, kommen darüber, dass sie sich für den Ballester irgendwie interessieren. Dazu habe ich jetzt ein bisschen den Faden verloren, wo ich eigentlich hinwollte.
Daraus wird der Polilog aus dem Dialog?
Genau, einen Dialog oder einen Polilog gibt es sowieso schon. Ich hoffe, dass dieser Supporters Club, den wir jetzt neu gegründet haben, wo Leute teilnehmen können, denen das ein Herzensanliegen ist, dass es den Ballesterer weiter gibt, die dafür auch eine kleine Spende, eine monatliche, machen und dass wir speziell mit denen auch in einen starken Austausch kommen und davon auch sehr viel profitieren. Was ist das, was diese Leute dann auch wollen? Was ist das, was wir machen können? Und vielleicht sind da auch Leute dabei, die dann eben auch die Seite wechseln und von Lesern oder Fans von uns dann vielleicht auch zu Schreibern oder Schreiberinnen werden und so weiter.
Philipp, du hast ja wahrscheinlich auch noch meine eigene Sicht drauf, weil es in den 20 Jahren 11Freunde auch immer wieder im deutschsprachigen Markt direkte Konkurrenten gab, kurzzeitig von 11Freunde. Also es gab mal aus dem Olympia Verlag, ich glaube, das war rund damals, es gab verschiedene andere Formate. Woran liegt es denn deiner Meinung nach, dass bis auf 11Freunde und vielleicht noch den tödlichen Pass, aber ich weiß nicht, ob man den dazurechnen soll, weil das eben in einer komplett anderen Dimension abläuft, aber den gibt es schon länger, ich glaube seit 1995 hier aus München heraus produziert. Woran liegt es, dass keiner sich auf diesem Markt behaupten konnte? Wie habt ihr die vom Markt rausgedrängt, Philipp? Pferdeköpfe in Betten?
Nein, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das große Problem war, dass ich vorhin schon mal angerissen habe, da entscheidend war, nämlich diese Überschätzung des Marktes. Der Olympia-Verlag ist ja damals mit rund in den Andi-Kiosk gegangen und dann gab es noch Player aus dem B&D-Verlag, die beide, glaube ich, dachten, hey, Fußballmarkt illustrierte großes Interesse, weltweites und bundesweites Interesse, das muss doch funktionieren. Und dann haben sie eben festgestellt, wie schwierig dieser Markt eigentlich ist und wie schwer es eigentlich ist, neben Sportbild, neben Kicker und dann auch eben uns überhaupt zu einer Art von Rentabilität zu kommen. Und man darf nicht vergessen, dass zu der Zeit Magazinengeschäft damals auch noch anders betrieben wurde. Also damals war man mit Auflagen unter 100.000 völlig unzufrieden. Damals galt alles, was so 30, 40, 50.000 Exemplare verkauft in Deutschland, als total floppt. Und das war zum Beispiel auch der Grund, warum dieses großartige Magazin Hetrick, das es ja in den 90ern gab, von Christoph Biermann und anderen gemacht, dann nicht zu Gruner und Jahr gegangen ist, weil die auch damals noch auf dem Trip waren, dass sie gesagt haben, hey, alles, was nicht 100.000 verkauft, da müsste ja gar nicht mit ankommen. Und ich glaube, dass dann irgendwann diese Verlage gesehen haben, hey, da steckt ja gar kein großes, geiles Geschäft hinter, wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben, sondern das ist mühsam und da muss man immer wieder um jede Anzeige kämpfen und so weiter. Das lassen wir doch lieber. Und dann haben eben Verlage schnell die Lust verloren. Das war bei uns eben anders, weil wir es schon ganz klein kannten, weil wir ja sehr organisch gewachsen sind. Die anderen Magazine hatten dann immer so einen relativ schnell großen Apparat mit 10 Redakteuren, 12 Grafikern, 14 Marketingleuten und so. Also ich glaube, das war jetzt nicht so, dass wir mit aggressiven Marketing, die vom Tableau gewischt hätten, sondern eher, die sind an ihren eigenen Ansprüchen und an ihren eigenen möglicherweise Überschätzungen gescheitert. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt auch finde, ich habe Rund immer gerne gelesen, ich habe den Player immer gerne gelesen, obwohl der ja auch eher ein Magazin war, Oliver Desk war, vom Kollegen Oliver Wurm. Also ich habe das immer gerne gelesen und ich glaube auch, dass noch weitere Magazine neben uns, neben dem Ballesterer durchaus guttäten am Markt. Also ich finde, wir haben ja alle unsere speziellen Ausformungen. Es gibt Dinge, die wir besonders gerne machen, es gibt Dinge, die der Ballesterer besonders gut kann. Also da wäre es eigentlich super, wenn es zum Beispiel noch etwas gäbe, was zum Beispiel wie 442 früher eher richtig Boulevardesque wäre, das quasi dann auch nochmal andere Geschichten erzählt. Also ich glaube, dass eine lebendige Print-Szene und eine lebendige Magazinszene eigentlich allen gut tun würde. Aber wie gesagt, da gibt es glaube ich auch jetzt nicht gerade das ganz große Interesse der Verlage zu sagen. Da ballern wir jetzt noch mal mit einem abweiteren Fußmagazin auf dem Markt.
Ja, ich glaube, für Verlage da reinzugehen, das ist schwierig. Es ist auch in Österreich – wir waren immer das Einzige, oder nicht immer das Einzige, es gab mal 08, auch ein schönes Magazin, das ich auch gern gelesen habe. Aber es sind mittlerweile in Österreich auch alle anderen Sportmagazine mehr oder weniger eingestellt worden. Also Wochenzeitungen, Monatszeitungen, was auch immer. Also ich glaube, dass alles, was von Verlagen kommt, die einfach mal glauben, okay, wir puttern da jetzt ein bisschen was rein und das wird schon funktionieren. Ich glaube, dass das so nicht funktioniert. Ich glaube, es hat zwar immer geheißen, jetzt Magazine gründen, das muss irgendwie verrückt sein, aber ich finde, wenn ich mir anschaue zum Beispiel, was die Kollegen und Kolleginnen von Zeitspielen in Deutschland machen, finde ich auch eine super Bereicherung. Also es ist ein schönes Magazin und würde ich auch sagen, hat auf dem Markt Platz. Und das, was der Philipp vorhin gesagt hat, würde ich da auch nochmal unterschreiben. Wir sind zwar in irgendeiner Form Konkurrenz, weil wir beide Fußballmagazine sind, aber es gibt eigentlich relativ wenige Überschneidungen, was die Ausrichtung. Oder auch die Themen unterscheidet sich oft sehr stark. Das ist meistens eine Ergänzung und nicht ein so muss man es machen. Der Fußball und sein Umfeld bieten so viele schöne Möglichkeiten, über den Sport, über die Welt, über die Gesellschaft zu sprechen, dass da auch viele nebeneinander existieren können, ohne dass man sich jetzt sagt, man kannibalisiert sich da irgendwie.
Kann ich aus persönlicher Erfahrung auch sagen, man kann beides parallel sehr gut lesen und hat nicht das Gefühl, dass man da irgendetwas doppelt lesen würde. Aber gleichzeitig haben wir ja auch die Entwicklung, wenn ihr jetzt sagt, naja, es wäre eigentlich auch schön, noch ein weiteres Magazin zu haben, das vielleicht einen anderen Schwerpunkt legt. Als du zum Beispiel gesagt hast, Philipp, das war das Thema, die man noch mal aus einem anderen Blickwinkel sieht, da war mein erster Gedanke, naja, das kriegt man ja als Fan schon. Da muss ich ja nur den Leuten auf Instagram folgen. Und wenn ich ausführliche Artikel oder Interviews mit Spielern lesen will von meiner Lieblingsmannschaft, dann gucke ich mir Vereinszeitschriften an und die sehen ja inzwischen aus wie Freunde doof gesagt. Also, das soll jetzt nicht als Beleidigung verstanden sein, aber die versuchen ja auch, sich den Anklang zu geben. Jedes kostenlose Magazin, eben keine Ahnung, DM oder in der Deutschen Bahn, wird heutzutage hergestellt von irgendeiner Agentur, die darauf spezialisiert ist, die dann auch richtige Journalisten dafür bezahlt, da mehr oder weniger tiefgehende Stücke für zu produzieren. Also, ich habe das Gefühl, jetzt aus Sicht des Fußballfans, der das konsumiert, gibt es doch eigentlich gerade schon alles und vielleicht ist das auch Teil des Problems.
Ja, ist es definitiv. Ich finde auch, es ist schon eine gewisse Chuzpe von den Vereinen, ständig Interviews mit ihren Spielern auf ihren Vereinskanälen als exklusiv anzupreisen. Denn natürlich haben sie das exklusiv. Es sind ja ihre Spieler und es sind ihre Kanäle. Und natürlich ist es so, dass vieles dann von außen aussieht, wie wir. Also, wenn ich mir das neue Vereinsmagazin vom FC Bayern anschaue, ist das tatsächlich ein Magazin, von dem ich denke, da kannst du auch 11 Freunde draufpappen und ein bisschen weniger PR im Berichterstattung, dann wäre es zumindest von der Grafik und von der Gestaltung und sehr, sehr ähnlich. Da denke ich halt immer schon, das ist dann schwierig für uns nochmal die Absetzbewegung zu machen. Ich glaube, du kannst dich eigentlich nur retten durch Unabhängigkeit, durch kritischen Journalismus, durch immer wieder Unbequem sein, weil das ist eigentlich das Einzige, was die nicht liefern, nämlich Distanz und Journalismus, klassischen Journalismus, der nicht durch Vereinsbrille oder PR-Brille gefärbt ist. Und vielleicht noch ein zweites ist tatsächlich bei uns zumindest, bei den Freunde eben auch Humor. Der kommt sicherlich bei uns manchmal auch ein bisschen studentisch daher, gerade im Netz so. Aber ich glaube trotz allem, dass in diesen ganzen Magazinen und auf den Instagram-Kanälen und so weiter eines eben nicht passiert, nämlich diesen ganzen klebrigen Pathos, der irgendwie den Fußball ja umwabert, den zu brechen und an der Realität zu überprüfen und zu schauen, stimmt das denn wirklich so? Das ist eben was, was kein Vereinsmagazin und kein Instagram-Account leistet, sondern das können dann doch eben nur Magazine wie El Freunde und Balestra oder das können dann auch nur Portale, wie es jetzt beispielsweise Spielverlagerungen ist oder das können eben auch nur so Podcastsachen wie Rasenfunk und andere. Also dieses ironisch, selbstironisch Punk-Rockesk, diese Sachen zu spiegeln, das ist eben eine Sache, das kriegt dann doch eben kein Kanal und kein Vereinsmagazin hin.
Der Humor als Absatzbewegung. Ja, ist so ein bisschen die Frage. Auf der anderen Seite hat ja jeder so, also das ist ja gerade die Gefahr oder was heißt Gefahr, aber das zeichnet das ja aus, dass man sich sehr für die eigene Sache begeistert, dass ich glaube, dass es auch in beim Rasenfunk, beim Ballestere, als auch bei Freunde gibt es auch wiederum Themengebiete, wo uns andere dann vorwerfen konnten, naja, da habt ihr dann vielleicht auch einen besonderen Pathos. Also bei mir wäre es dann wahrscheinlich der Fokus total auf Taktik und wo man sich dann eben auch überdreht und dann das leichte Abkippen des Außenverteidigers wichtiger findet, als dass jemand ein Eigentor geschossen hat, jetzt doof gesagt. Und bei Freunden und Ballestere ist es vielleicht auch gerade dieser Rückgriff auf die auf die gute alte Zeit in Anführungszeichen jetzt zu versehen, wo auch Leute sagen könnten, naja, da habt ihr ja auch euren Bereich, wo ihr so fest dran hängt. Also ich bin mir da manchmal gar nicht so sicher. Ich möchte dir gerne zustimmen. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob ich, ob ich mich jetzt also zum Beispiel den Rasenfunk, ob man den da so komplett rausnehmen könnte. Wenn man halt für eine Sache brennt, dann stürzt man sich da so drauf und überdreht halt auch. Und ob da dann immer noch für jeden auch mal die ironische Distanz dazu zu sehen ist, weiß ich nicht.
Also ist bei uns tatsächlich so. Ich sehe auch so blinde Flecke. Also ich würde noch nicht mal sagen, dass wir die Vergangenheit per se verklären. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass manches von dem, was uns heute noch als gute alte Zeit erscheint, also tatsächlich so diese 80er, 70er Jahre, die – was die 80er Jahre angeht – für mich natürlich auch verklärt sind als die Zeit, in der ich zum Fußball gefunden habe und die ich auch deswegen noch besonders intensiv in Erinnerung habe, weil sie halt diese Neuentdeckung eines wahnsinnig aufregenden Gebietes für mich war. Also für mich war es, als ich das erste Mal auf die Alm gegangen bin in Bielefeld, unfassbar aufregend, dass da viele, viele tausend Leute auf den Rängen stehen und Schimpfworte brüllen und rauchen und Bier trinken und sich gegenschmeißen lassen. Also das war tatsächlich für mich eine Welt, die ich damals staunend und fasziniert und begeistert so wahrgenommen habe und da muss man quasi es mir nachsehen, dass ich darauf jetzt nicht den knallharten soziologischen, historischen, sozialwissenschaftlichen Blick habe, dass ich sezieren kann, dass du natürlich in den 80ern auch viel Rassismus auf den Rängen gehabt hast, dass das die Hochzeit der Hooligans war, dass das die Hochzeit von chauvinistischen Sprüchen war. Ja, stimmt alles. Es war aber für mich ganz persönlich dann eben doch das, was Klaus Teweleit-Mator zur Welt genannt hat. Also Erklärmodell, all das. Also von daher hat da jeder seinen blinden Fleck. Das mag für dich die Taktik sein oder Faszination von taktischen Systemen. Das war für mich sicher diese Zeit, in der man das so kennengelernt hat. Das hat, glaube ich, jeder. Und ja, da muss man mit leben und muss irgendwann möglicherweise trotz allem aus dieser Verklärung raus. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich ein lebenslanger Prozess für uns alle.
Ja, ich sehe die Verklärung oder ich sehe das Problem nicht so groß. Also ich glaube schon, dass es das natürlich gibt und dass sich das dann auch in den Kreisen, in denen wir halt irgendwie gerade, die dann vielleicht redaktionelle Entscheidungen treffen oder so, dass da natürlich blinde Flecken da sind. Ich glaube, dass da wichtig ist, was wir vorher schon gesagt haben, eben diesen Austausch auch nach außen oder mit einer größeren Gruppe und auch den internen. Das ist ein Austausch in der in der Redaktion, ja. Also wenn man sagt, okay, ich weiß, ich hab da vielleicht einen blinden Fleck, dann schau ich drauf, dass vielleicht jemand, der da speziell sensibel drauf ist, über den Text schaut, den ich zu dem Thema schreib.
Ja, okay, gut, klar, das stimmt, aber vielleicht muss ich noch ein bisschen erklären, wie ich zu der Frage komme. Also dass ich mich zum Beispiel im Rasenfunk so auf Analyse fokussiere, das hängt ja nicht damit zusammen, dass ich mit einer Taktik-Tafel auf die Welt gekommen wäre. Ganz im Gegenteil, Philipp, du hast mich 2008 noch erlebt. Da hatte ich auch noch einen anderen Blick auf Fußball. Ich weiß nicht, welche Erinnerungen du hast, aber ich weiß noch, also ich weiß noch, dass ich da auch noch lange Haare hatte im ersten Teil meines Praktikums. Es ist wirklich schon ewig lange her. Aber der Grund, warum ich mich da so drauf fokussiere, ist, weil mich so viel anderes am Fußball so wahnsinnig nervt und ich das so wahnsinnig irrelevant finde. Und deswegen fokussiere ich mich auf die Taktik, also sprich, weil alles drumherum so ätzend ist oder vieles davon einfach ätzend geworden ist, suche ich mir diesen einen Bereich, der eben auch noch sehr viel mit dem Sport zu tun hat. Und ich liebe halt einfach das Spiel Fußball, sowohl es zu spielen als auch es zu gucken. Und daher kommt so ein bisschen meine Sorge. Und klar, ihr habt natürlich Mechanismen, um eure blinden Flecken nicht so sehr durchscheinen zu lassen auf eure Produkte. Das stimmt. Aber was machen wir drei denn, wenn der Fußball sich weiter so entwickelt, dass er einfach in vielen Bereichen einfach nur noch ätzend ist und man eigentlich gar keine Lust mehr hat, sich damit zu beschäftigen?
Also ich bin ja Kulturoptimist bei so was. Also ich glaube halt, dass es natürlich trotz allem immer Nischen geben wird. Der geschätzte Kollege Pascal Kloth von knapp daneben in der Schweiz, der hat mal ein wunderbares Buch rausgegeben über die Flachpassbar im Stadion von Zürich. Da wurde einfach das kulturelle Leben in dieser Stadionkneipe geschildert und man bekam in diesem Buch einen wunderbaren Blick darauf, wie Fußball funktionieren kann als Begegnungsstätte. Und er hat darin zwei Sätze formuliert, die ich ganz beeindruckend fand, nämlich er hat sich gefragt, was wir im Fußball eigentlich suchen und die zweite Frage, ob wir das, was wir im Fußball suchen, in Zukunft noch auch im Fußball finden werden und ich glaube, das ist so tatsächlich die entscheidende Frage, die wir uns alle stellen müssen. Was suchen wir denn eigentlich und finden wir das beim Fußball? Und ich habe bei all dem, was passiert ist, bei all dem, was an Kommerzialisierung passiert ist, an Versitzplatzung, an Preisschilds überall dran gehängt und so und an Eventisierung und an Fahnenpässen und Sky, Superclash, Gigantenbewerbung und so weiter, habe ich trotz allem, trotz allem im Fußball immer noch wunderbare Momente erlebt, ob es mit Aminia ist oder ob es vom Fernseher ist oder mit Freunden und so weiter. Fußball gibt mir immer noch viel, viel, viel zu viel, als dass ich irgendwie auch nur andersweise daran denken würde, ey mir reicht es jetzt oder ich gehe nur noch in die Kreisliga. Also das ist tatsächlich am Ende dann ja auch, glaube ich, so eine Entscheidung, ob man diesen ganzen Scheiß, den es drum herum gibt, diese ganzen Nervereien, diese ganze Geldgier, diese ganzen gierigen Funktionäre mit Dollarzeichen in den Augen, ob man das aushält, weil man sagt, der Fußball an sich ist trotzdem so großartig, so wunderbar und für mich so wichtig im Leben oder ob man dann irgendwann so zynisch wird und sagt, ja leck mich doch am Arsch. Das ist alles nichts mehr für mich. Also die Tendenz gibt es ja auch und die Leute gibt es ja auch. Also ich kenne viele, die sagen, hey, Muffi-Fußball, kein Bock mehr. Kann ich auch verstehen, für mich ist es aber irgendwie keine Alternative, ich komme da nicht raus quasi.
Stockholmsyndrom.
Ich glaube auch, dass es da zwei Aspekte gibt, also der eine Aspekt ist quasi, wie geht es einem persönlich, also dir oder dem Philipp oder mir mit dem Fußball und das andere ist halt, wie geht es dem Medium mit dem Thema. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn der Fußball nicht auch so scheiße wäre, dann gäbe es unsere Medien nicht. Also das ist ja, das war ja irgendwie so schon Gründungsmotivation, also das ist ja das, was wir auch am Anfang besprochen haben quasi, zu sagen, okay, uns war von Beginn an wichtig, zu sagen, wir sind gegen diese Kommerzialisierung, die es im Fußball gibt oder wir sind gegen, weiß ich nicht, Stehplatzverbot oder was auch immer. Das heißt, es gab ja immer schon das Bedürfnis, Kritik zu üben und Kritik an den Zuständen, die jetzt sind. Und ich würde sagen, das wird nicht weniger, so wie sich der Fußball entwickelt. Also dieses Bedürfnis zu sagen, okay, so wie es rennt, geht es oder das ist nicht gut, so wie es läuft. Ich glaube, dass das heute noch mindestens genauso, wenn nicht viel mehr, gilt als vor 20 Jahren. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, so als Medium sehe ich zumindest für einen Ballesterer die Verantwortung, das auch so weiterzumachen. Ich würde nicht ausschließen, dass dann ich irgendwann sage, okay, ich kann mich mit dem nicht auseinandersetzen, ich pack das einfach nimmer. Und ich habe schon so oft die Hoffnung gehabt, dass mir der Fußball noch mehr zurückgibt oder was auch immer. Das ist das eine. Aber ich würde sagen, dass die Notwendigkeit für das Medium genau dort hinzuschauen und zu sagen, und auch die Dinge auch noch zu suchen oder auch vielleicht zu schauen, findet man sie noch? Also irgendwie um das Karlswendung da irgendwie an auch wieder aufzugreifen. Ich glaube, die Aufgabe wird nicht weniger.
Okay, da habt ihr mir jetzt ein bisschen Hoffnung gegeben. Ich wollte auch nicht so negativ aus dieser Sendung rausgehen, deswegen hatte ich sowieso noch eine weitere Frage abschließend im Hinterkopf und zwar ein bisschen jetzt aus der Hüfte geschossen. Aber was sind eure liebsten Erinnerungen, wenn ihr an eure Zeit bei 20 Jahre Ballesterer, wenn auch nicht komplett dabei, Jakob schon klar, und 20 Jahre Freunde zurückdenkt? Jakob, du musst vorlegen, was ist deine Lieblingsanekdote, die du erlebt hast, ein Ereignis, was du nicht missen wollen würdest, was dir mit dem Ballesterer passiert ist?
Also jetzt, von einer persönlichen Geschichte her, würde ich sagen, das ist jetzt auch nichts besonders Schönes oder so gewesen, aber ich würde sagen, das prägendste für mich, oder das wichtigste Erlebnis war sicherlich 2008 gemeinsam mit dem Reinhardt, meinem Vorgänger, die Napoli-Fans nach Rom begleitet haben zum ersten Spiel der Saison. Und bei dem Spiel hat es halt alle möglichen Schwierigkeiten gegeben, also damals waren Sonderzüge in Italien schon verboten, Trinitalia hat aber trotzdem eigentlich einen eingerichtet, es war Hochsommer, heiß, schwierig, eine Auswärtsfahrt mit allen möglichen Schikanen quasi. Und herausgekommen ist dann, dass das Ganze erzählt worden ist, so okay, wieder mal die Napoli-Fans und wieder mal es hat Ausschreitungen gegeben und was auch immer. Relativ viel ist dort eigentlich nicht passiert. Medial oder massenmedial ist das halt alles die Erzählung von den italienischen Bahnen und von der Polizei quasi übernommen worden. Der Innenminister hat noch am selben Abend mehr oder weniger gesagt, okay, Napoli-Fans dürfen jetzt eine Saison auch nicht auswärtsfahren. Riesenthema überall. Und der Rheinland und ich waren da halt irgendwie mittendrin und haben dann quasi mit Kollegen vom Standard einer Tageszeitung gesprochen und gesagt, Leute, wenn euch das interessiert, wir wären da, wir könnten dazu was sagen. Und das Ganze hat sich dann, mit der Zeit ist es dann in Italien wieder aufgegriffen worden, ist dann wieder zurückgekommen und wir haben wahnsinnig viel Feedback oder positive Meldungen bekommen von Leuten, die sagen, okay, na irgendwie ist da ja vielleicht doch was anderes passiert als das, was kommuniziert worden ist. Es ist dann ein Fernsehteam der Reihe gekommen, hat uns in Wien in der alten Redaktion auch besucht, es ist unser Bericht irgendwie im italienischen Parlament zitiert worden, also das war so, würde ich sagen, wahrscheinlich irgendwie für die Geschichte meines Lebens. Da war ich gerade zwei Jahre dabei, also vielleicht zu früh gekommen. Wenn sie später gekommen wäre, dann hätte ich vielleicht auch besser gewusst, wie man Geschichten schön erzählt oder so. Aber da würde ich sagen, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht so die klassische Anekdote, aber das ist so ein total prägendes Erlebnis, das mich mit meinen Jahren im Ballestra natürlich verbindet.
Damals hat Kai Tippmann dazu geschrieben, der war auch schon hier im Rasenfunk zu Gast in seinem Blog, glaube ich, hat er das geschrieben. Eine kleine Redaktion eines 20.000 Auflageplatz hatte mal eben den millionenschweren Redaktionsstuben die Unterhosen heruntergezogen, weil ihr eben zufällig da mit dabei wart und dann die Berichterstattung korrigieren konntet, um es mal so zu sagen.
Ja, nein, genau, also war wirklich Wahnsinn. Also auch, würde ich sagen, nicht geplant ist besser als im Traum das hier.
Sowas gibt es auch mal. Philipp, was ist deine liebste Erinnerung an 20 Jahre, Freunde?
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass es so die eine Anekdote gibt, aber…
Du kannst auch zehn erzählen, wir haben Zeit.
Das ist das Schönste, was ich wirklich bei der Arbeit von Elfreund immer wieder sehe, dass man die ganzen Helden von damals, die man so aus dem Fernsehkannte plötzlich dann in Natura trifft und überprüfen kann, ob das wunderbare Bild, das man von diesen Leuten hatte, ob das wirklich stimmt. Karl-Heinz Förster, ein großes Idol meiner Jugend. Ich habe mir sogar die Haare so gekämpft wie Karl-Heinz Förster. Ich fand den ganz großartig, den Treter mit dem Engelsgesicht, wie es so schön hieß, und der entpuppte sich dann als wahnsinnig netter, umgänglicher Typ. Lothar Matthäus war genauso, wie man ihn sich vorstellt. Man denkt immer, der ist komplett anders, aber dann ist er genauso und hat in dem Hotel in Budapest auch gleich die Kellnerin angebaggert und seine damalige Ehegattin weggedrückt am Telefon. Solche Sachen fand ich immer echt sehr, sehr schön. Aber tatsächlich hat mir Ewald Lin, der ja ein Freund des Hauses geworden ist, einen Kindheitstrauma quasi entledigt. Denn 1982 bin ich mit meinem Bruder zum Eröffnungstraining von Arminia gegangen auf der Radrennbahn in Bielefeld und wollte ein Autogramm haben und alle gaben noch welche, Larger Pol und Helmut Schröder und Wolfgang Kneipp usw. Aber Ewald Lin schaute uns an und sagte, mein Autogramm ist doch nicht mehr wert als eures. Unterschreibt ihr doch selber, euer Autogramm ist genauso wert. Und mein Bruder Ronald, ich guckte uns an und sagte, Ewald, das ist dein Autogramm, das ist tausendmal mehr wert als unseres. Dann habe ich Ewald Lin im Zuge einer Reportage 2003 mal getroffen und dann erzählte ich ihm etwas im Überschwang diese Geschichte, worauf mich Ewald Lin dann erstmal nur in einer Mischung aus Spott und Verachtung anguckte und meinte, es wird ja wohl ihre persönliche Entwicklung nicht allzu gehemmt haben, dass ich ihnen kein Autogramm gegeben habe. Und dann meinte ich, nein, nein. Dann zog ich von dann und neulich, da hatten wir noch mal eine Veranstaltung gemeinsam, da hatten wir dann endlich ein Autogramm gegeben. Und das war – eigentlich hätte ich danach den ganzen Bums dicht machen können, weil schöner kann es nicht mehr werden.
Die Initialzündung war das verwehrte Autogramm von Ewald Lin 1982. Man weiß es nicht, ob er bis hierhin gekommen ist. Aber solche Geschichten schreibt einfach nur der Fußball und solche Geschichten schreibt nur ihr in Elfreund und im Ballesterer. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, dass ihr euch trotz Homeoffice, trotz technischer Probleme, die es anscheinend jetzt bei jeder Rasenfunkaufzeichnung während Corona gibt, man kann sich vorstellen, woran das liegt, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich empfehle nochmal sehr gerne an dieser Stelle das große Elfreunde-Buch. Erschienen bei Heiner Hardcover. 456 Seiten für 25 Euro. Sehr schön. Vor allem, als du vorhin von dem erotischen Verhältnis zu Print gesprochen hast, da fies mir wieder ein. Ich habe hier immer wieder darin herum geblättert. Und es riecht einfach so geil. Es ist einfach diese... Es ist einfach so. Es kommt dazu bei Printmagazinen. Da lasse ich mir von niemandem was anderes erzählen. Frisch gekaufte Bücher oder Magazine. Da kommt noch etwas euphaktorisches dazu. Also kann ich sehr empfehlen, ein sehr schönes Buch mit mega tollen Bildern. Aber das wusste man ja bei Freunde auch schon, dass es das sein würde. Also Philipp, vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast. Danke natürlich auch an Jakob Rosenberg. Unterstützt alle den Ballesterer. Ich denke, ihr habt mehr als nur einen Grund gehört in den vorangegangenen Zeit. Warum man den Ballesterer unterstützen sollte, werdet ihr Teil des Ballesterer-Supporters-Clubs. Jakob, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Und ich drücke euch alle Daumen, dass ihr dem Trend etwas entgegensetzen könnt. Und dass wir dann irgendwann in 20 Jahren die 40 Jahre Show machen, wo wir dann auch wissen, was aus dem Rasenfunk geworden ist. Ob ich wirklich verzweifelt bin an allem. Danke dir, Jakob, dass du mit dabei warst.
Herzlichen Dank und ich freue mich auf die nächste Sendung in 20 Jahren.
Vielleicht kriegen wir es ja auch ein bisschen früher hin. Danke euch beiden. Danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Podcast-Grüße können natürlich jetzt nur rausgehen an die wilde Liga, der Podcast von Elfreunde, den man normalerweise nicht so einfach hören kann, weil er bei Audible hinterlegt ist. Aber aktuell, und damit meine ich jetzt im März 2020, ist Audible für jeden frei zugänglich. Also kann man auch mal die wilde Liga hören. Tut es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und hört natürlich auch gerne den Rasenfunk. Ich freue mich, wenn ihr bald mal wieder mit dabei seid. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.